in the last video we introduced the idea
that we could represent any arbitrary
periodic function by a series of
weighted cosines and sines and what I'm
going to start doing in this video is
starting to establish our mathematical
foundation so it'll be pretty
straightforward for us to find these
coefficients that give us that function
so the first thing I want to do the
first thing I'm going to do is establish
some truths using you or some truths
with the definite integrals I'm going to
focus over the interval 0 to 2pi over
this video in the next few videos
because the function we're approximating
has a period of 2pi it completes one
cycle from 0 to 2pi we could have done
it over other intervals of length 2 pi
and if this period was other than 2pi we
would have done it over intervals of
that period but I'm focusing on 2pi
because it makes the math a little bit
cleaner and a little bit simpler and
then we can generalize in the future so
let's just establish some things about
integrated integrals of trig functions
so the first thing I want to establish I
want to establish that the definite
integral from 0 to 2pi of sine of M X DX
actually let me stay in T since we're
since our original function is in terms
of T sine of M T DT I want to establish
that that is equal to 0 for any non-zero
integer M for non non zero nonzero
integer integer M and I also want to
establish that the integral from 0 to
2pi of cosine of M T DT is equal to 0
for any nonzero integer M and you might
already take this for granted or you
feel good about it or you've already
proven it to yourself and if so you
could actually skip this video but let's
work through it because it's it's
actually a good review of some integral
calculus here so let's first do this
this top one so let me just rewrite the
integral we're gonna take the integral
from 0 to 2pi
of sine M T DT now we know we want to
take the antiderivative sine of M T so
we know that the we know that the
derivative with respect to T of cosine M
T is equal to what is this this is going
to be equal to M the derivative of M T
with respect to T times the derivative
of cosine M T with respect to M T so
times negative sine of M T or we could
write this is going to be equal to
negative M sine of M T I could put a
parenthesis there if I like and so I
almost have negative M sine of empty I
just don't have a negative M here so
what if I put a negative M there but I
can't just do that that would change the
value of the expression but I could I
could also multiply by negative 1 over m
now these two would if we take the
product they're going to cancel out it
we're going to get our original
expression but this is useful because
now we can say this is equal to negative
1 over m and now the antiderivative of
this business right over here we know is
cosine M T so it's going to be cosine M
T cosine M T evaluated at 2 pi and 0 2
pi and 0 and so this is going to be
equal to this is equal to negative 1
over m times cosine of M times 2 pi let
me write this way
cosine cosine of M times 2 pi minus
cosine of well it's going to be M times
0 which is just going to be we could
just write that as 0 and so let's see
cosine of any multiple of 2 pi well
that's just going to be 1 and cosine of
0 well that's also 1 so you have 1 minus
1 is 0 times negative 1 over M well this
is all going to evaluate to this is the
result we wanted this is all going to
evaluate to 0 so we have just
proven that first statement so now let's
prove the second one it's going to be a
very similar argument so let's rewrite
it we're going to get the integral from
0 to 2pi of cosine of M T DT and now let
me engineer this a little bit we know
that the derivative of sine of M T is M
cosine M T so let me multiply and divide
by M multiplied by M and divide by M not
changing the actual value and so this is
going to be equal to 1 over m and then
the antiderivative of we find a nice
color here the antiderivative of that
right over there
let me see I should say the
antiderivative of this right over here
is sine of M T so sine of M T notice the
derivative of sine of M T is M cosine
empty and we're going to evaluate that
at from 0 to 2pi so this is going to be
equal to we still have our 1 over m out
front 1 over m and so this is going to
be sine of sine of M times 2 pi or we
could say 2 pi M 2 pi M minus sine of M
times 0 so sine I'm going to write that
as sine of 0 and what's the sine of any
multiple of 2 pi remember M is a nonzero
integer so any multiple it's going to be
a multiple of 2 pi here well that's just
going to be 0 and sine of 0 is just
going to be 0
so this whole thing this whole thing is
just going to be 0 and so we have
established our second statement there
so this is this is going to be a nice
base to to build from and now we're
going to we're going to do slightly more
complex integrals in the next few videos
so that it's going to be hopefully
pretty straightforward to find our
Fourier coefficients with a little bit
of calculus and algebraic manipulation